never in my life did I
think that there would be a perfect
Synergy between barol and Taylor Swift
fans yeah it's crazy they they don't
look normal to I don't know what the
hell's going on now I I haven't F I love
Gossip Dave she she's generally like a
very private person so is she yeah with
her da no with her dating while they're
dating oh before she yes yeah before she
songs about CTE are going to be amazing
it's crazy czy thr a car they [__]
he's driving it looks like it's out a
the whole thing looks he's driving like
it almost it looks like an Olden po
convertible like it's crazy it just they
don't look I'm fascinated by it and the
internet is blowing it's like the it's
all anyone's talking this is as close as
Taylor Swift will get to dating a black
dude that's as close as it's gonna
happen is Travis Kelsey he's right there
he we we kind of claim him I mean he got
the Impala he got the haircut and I
don't know it's in Impala but this big
like it was a maroon like convertible so
yeah I'm shocked by it I I am I play
into it I
don't I don't know I I I've never been
the biggest Kelsey guy I've met him a
few times he's super nice in person now
he's dating Taylor Swift I don't know
what to think it's crazy podcast with
his brother is hilarious amazing amazing
content he seems like a nice fun dude
now he could probably get any girl he
wants it's a handsome some guys [__]
huge successful Taylor Swift I would
have to say yes but Taylor Swift isn't
is part of it are you seduced by the
fame of that's I think that's what he is
because Taylor Swift isn't oh boy Dave
don't don't say wait say it
say let me just take those friendship
bracelets
off look people this is Swifty Community
[__] Adell Dave loves Sally he's a great
but I want and I don't think anybody
would put her up
as like a sex Sy okay one bite everyone
knows but she's not you know she not
notor model she's she's like an
equestrian model yo a little bit she has
beautiful face beautiful equestri very T
put in one of them little helmets Yeah
Yeah but so is he yeah which makes it
work yeah dude I think he but are you
saying that he could do better is that
what no no no it it depends she's you
can't do bigger or better I mean belich
today he quoted he says Travis Kel's had
a lot of great catches is the best catch
he's ever made in is talking about so
Funny's Michael Jackson and he that's
what's impressive is bich had a banger
for it yeah he's good she's she's the
biggest person almost on the planet
right now yeah not even close but is she
like are we who who's he wants to No I'm
trying to think like uh Christy Brinkley
in our Prime no I don't think anyone
would say that yeah but
no we're having Boomer moments today
today I had a tag on my shirt and Dave
Dave and I didn't realize it and Dave
just goes hey uh is that a thing now are
we leaving the tags on like I I honestly
didn't know you're capable of anything
I've seen you the itly looks I'm like I
don't know maybe that's what they're
doing they're wearing [__] tags on
his shirts nowadays and their armpits I
don't know wait butan Travis Kelsey you
don't get the appeal I mean in terms of
superficial Travis are for women in
general and yeah he's a guy he's got
everything great looking guy athletic
tall Rich famous doofus no he kind he's
super cool to me I'm be honest that's
the gay thing I said on this podcast
he's super I don't think so I think you
need to see color more I I think he's
kind of for a white guy I think it
doesn't get that much cooler no no like
there's different he's not Odell Beckham
Jr no but if I'm going like what I think
is cool and I'm going to date myself
here a little bit like Clooney Brad P
those guys are like cool I don't like
Travis Kel's style at all I think he's a
little bit cringy the man had his own
dating show like that if you have a
dating show that's a little cringey
what's it called everyone wants to suck
my
dick
Le yeah so there you go
you know everybody he's the
coolest like Leonardo Caprio is not
doing like a dating show I don't know he
a little corny to me he's a little
cornball to me but Taylor may be a
little bit too you think that he's corny
meaning like his interests are corny or
the the fact that he wants to be famous
outside of being an athlete like well I
I I think he who he's addicted to the
fame a little bit but like his quote
like hey supposedly this is what they
said he said on the mcab show like Hey
Taylor I saw you rock like meti why
don't you to come see me rock Arrowhead
like
lame oh his pickup line yeah like that's
[__] lame yeah I bet if you go back
through your pickup lines though you
would be like oh God it tell tell me
point in this interview where I'm like
I'm Rico
Suave [__] Travis Kelce to me I mean
I'm I'm saying that's a universal Travis
Kelce is a great looking dude I get it
he's a professional athlete that has
great appeal I do think he's a little
[__] corny so what you're trying to
say is that you put Taylor up so high
that you expect some Rico Suave [__] to
catch her yeah yeah no but maybe she
doesn't want that maybe she wants
somebody bit great dick who [__]
knows I don't know what
I but he's a big [__] good-look
professional athlete I do think and this
is before Taylor I always thought he was
a little bit corny on the field and the
things he says and does like [__] he
the Chiefs lose a game and he's like
it's all my fault put it on my should
like what are you talking about you lost
by 30 like I don't know what you're
talking about nice guy men person so he
is a nice dude but I do think he's got a
decent amount of cheese ball to him okay
so what happens with these guys like
sorry real quick who's your ideal match
for Taylor what guy you get to pick any
guy what guy deserves that yeah
relationship I don't even know like I
would see her dating and it doesn't mean
it's right like I see her more of like a
Daniel Jones guy if we're going in the
NFL like she seems like more along that
the [__] are you
talking you disrespect Taylor with
Daniel Jones what the [__] an NFL
quarterback yeah we kind we know sign a
big [__] deal you think Daniel Jones
or may I I think that's a pretty [__]
like good I'm going to stay in the NFL I
don't know she got to go Brady yeah like
Brady's maybe a little old for her yeah
that's yeah
but Kelsey got two
rings yeah I'm just saying their
personality to me are
closer what I just I just don't cuz he's
just if the Pro Bowl is happening and
Daniel Jones wants to go to buy a ticket
to Hawaii you know what I
mean that's what I'm saying with
disrespectful if you guys are talking
about like who's had the more successful
career and talented I'm not I'm just
saying like where I fit who all right
let me give a thought who I would be
like a good match for teller I may be
I'll get back to you later in the show
I don't think it's like that think he's
a true Swift yeah I don't look I have no
interest like sexually in Taylor Swift I
call her mother so I have no interest
like what mother wants mother gets like
fine I have no interest that sounded
sexual weirdly though Weir that's what
that's you don't know how to not shoot
that's the thing like even in a
compliment he's still shooting her what
the [__] Swifty say it's like oh they
call her mother like get
educated I'm trying to like uh who's
like a young oh
Gyllenhaal okay Jake they've done that
though they've done that there you're
not a Swifty no I know they've done it
don't do this where you pretend you I
was going through I I know them all
trust me I
know
may give me friendship bracelets bro you
don't deserve how you name somebody what
about John Mayor is that another I just
said mayor I know I [__] I know them
all what I it's like if I said [__]
Scooter Braun next I scooter would be
good mental [__] up scooter would be
good don't try to trap
me I'm trying to think who's like a a
youngish oh I got him the the kid who
played Spider-Man Tom Holland oh she's
twice as tall as Tom Andrew Garfield
Garfield bang that's the relationship
Garfield and Swift put down the books
that's the relationship wait why what
just works no Y what mean no I mean
Garfield is like half gay like I I don't
I think she needs a little bit more men
she TL she's like 5'11 very skinny
though yeah but she's she's she's like a
model Garfield's like 5'8 or something
like that he's an actor sham probably
sh's too young can't handle that you
need a man's man you need a Kelsey you
need a
just what I actually think is I think
they're great together dude I root for
them I'm not rooting against them it's
just surprising to me is what I
said surprising to me is what I said
it's not first pick come on let me see
this is what
did mil if it's not too much trouble
hold on hold on hold on that's crazy why
you don't like the color of the car it's
just like she's so Pro they're it's
almost like they're doing it as a
publicity stunt they drive away in a
convertible so you want true love that's
the thing that no no I'm happy for him
listen she wants to have her fun and
Travis seems like a nice guy it's just a
strange pairing to me but I who am I to
[__] say God this what happens you're
[__] rich and successful now you get
seduced by different things I imagine
I'm happy for her yes it's but you're
asking me like I would have never I
could have picked a million people and
he wanted have been on the list of being
like yeah that works I do think aside
from her he struck me as kind of like a
cringy type guy that would maybe get
like you know girls going to the Jersey
Shore DJs what he what Travis do he took
that one of your [__] got got to be
he lost a bet he lost a big bet on he
took down is the Patriots I think that's
what he took down actually the I only
Chief ever beat the Pats in playoffs and
gr's the greatest tight end of all time
oh this is a grank thing it's not gr I
like my fantasy tight end grank was I
think better at his Peak but Travis is
long Tris is great I'm gr got beat up
yeah yeah he played a long time listen
Travis is [__] great he's a nice guy
ion see them together I do think he's a
little corny who cares there's nothing
wrong with being corny nothing wrong
with gr and Taylor Swift works though
can Dr grank and Taylor Swift that works
yeah that works maybe we'll see what
happens